foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I love my father I love my brother I
love my family I always do nothing of
what I've done in this book or otherwise
has ever been to any intention to harm
them or hurt them the need for her to
rehabilitate her image that made her
dangerous that made her dangerous
because of the connections that she was
forging within the British press in the
Oprah interview you accuse members of
your family of racism you don't even
well oh the British press said that all
of the family members that live within
the Windsor and Ascot area you're
Jumping On a Plane together playing with
12 14 maybe 16 seats you were not
invited on that place not invited oh
shut up
[Music]
well good ladies Rolanda welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored I took two weeks
off and all hell broke loose
let me start with you you like most
people uh get a kicking in the book he
dismisses you as self-serving writing a
book just to put one side of the of the
point of view I mean I had to laugh when
I read that this is by a guy who's
literally just done exactly that
yes but please you knew my story at the
time I was being Trashed by everyone and
I went to the highest court in the land
and I had to survive I had to feed my
family I would everything I had was
taken away from me Harry's in a totally
different position he's an angry
petulant privileged prince who
constantly blames others for with no
accountability on his part his mother
would be absolutely appalled by don't
only Ant-Man himself he's undermining
his country his family the institution
which is the monarchy which his mother
was very proud of
um Beggar's belief I don't recognize the
young man that I grew up with I don't
recognize that man anymore I I just
don't know what's happened to him I
think he's lost the plot completely
appears this book shouldn't be called
Sperry should be called blame because
he's blaming everybody else but himself
yeah I completely agree and also I've
never seen an unhappier looking person
who constantly tells us how happy he is
this is not a happy man he's bitter
bitter bitter no and there seems to be
no end to the bitterness
no and you have to remember our dearly
Queen had to suffer this too before she
died because she also watched the Oprah
Winfrey interview and and thought what
on Earth is happening here why didn't
Harry come and talk to me about this so
she went to her grave actually not
knowing the truth with great distress
which Harry compounded in her final days
of her life well I think she I honestly
think the queen will be turning in a
grave reading all this stuff and reading
the Fallout
um because not not only did that Oprah
Winfrey interview air literally a couple
of days after Philip was taken to
hospital and as we later know died
within several months but the book has
now come out within three months of the
queen dying and there is his response to
the death of our great Monarch is within
three months to do a book which causes
severe damage to the institution that
she represented so magnificently for
over 70 years
I
I totally agree and Piers you remember
those boys growing up you saw them grow
up you came to Canada Palace out in
those days Diana always had the final
word so I'm going to leave you with my
my words which I think Diana would be
saying right now she'd be saying to
Harry jumping up and down wanted to be
noticed
Harry be quiet
yeah you do wonder who on Earth is
having that conversation with him what's
good at Trisha got us so Trisha you know
you were there on Good Morning Britain
on the day the uh well the morning after
the Oprah Winfrey interview air we had a
pretty Lively series of exchanges on
that show as you know I left Good
Morning Britain the next day because I
uh was asked to apologize for
disbelieving her claims of racism I said
I wanted to see evidence of this
so-called racism we now learn from
Harry's own mouth that they did not call
the royal family races after all uh so
I'm not quite sure why I had to leave my
job are you
yes
um because they actually didn't use the
words racist oh please and
would you like me to finish no I tell
you what I want to do Trisha before you
go any further I want to play you what
they said on Oprah then you can repeat
what you've just said let's watch this
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about how dark your baby is going
to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like what was that conversation
that conversation I'm never going to
share
um but at the time
at the time it was awkward I was a bit
shocked
and the end of that first clip of Meghan
Markle goes on to say that if the baby
was too dark that would be a problem yes
you may think that that I'm afraid
Trisha that is racism
the charge was racism against the royal
family at the time they produced no
evidence her version of events was
nearly two years after Harry's timeline
when this happened they've never named
The Royal member who said this stuff and
now we get told casually it's not racism
all right can you just play that again
because there must be something wrong at
my line I didn't hear either Harry or
Megan use the word racism I heard you
use it I saw the Press use it I didn't
actually hear them use the word and
that's what when we had that a robust
exchange of of words I think what I said
to you is that I do get fed up with
other people labeling white people
labeling what is and isn't racist to to
black people now if they'd actually use
the word racism
honestly this is utterly ridiculous so
what is racism I'll tell you what racism
is I'll tell you what racism
I know I'm white Morgan's about to
lecture a black woman about racism
I'm about to give you an example of
racism as a middle-aged white man who I
know is the enemy because you know let
me tell you one example is an example of
racism would be somebody expressing
concern about the skin color of a baby
from a mixed race marriage and when the
when the interviewer then says what if
it was darker that would be a problem
yes you may think that that is an
example of somebody expressing racism
and that became the headline and
narrative for the next two years after
the interview and for you to shamelessly
sit there and pretend that wasn't what
they meant is upper if there were more
black people in the media in the you
know in the Tabloid media they may have
had the opportunity to look into that
and explain it a little bit more I
didn't see it as racism I saw it and
that's why I got crossed when you you
decided to label it later I didn't
decide to do anything I well in that in
when we were having they literally
confirmed Oprah Winfrey
attempts to talk about this in other
than headline news when I'm trying to
have a recent conversation I get shouted
over why is my experience or what black
people experience why do we have no
currency why uh they've literally had
front pages about the racist royal
family for two years how much more does
Meghan Markle no one has no one has
called the the royal family racist I
mean I I forgot I want to see this is I
would say it's built on built on the
Commonwealth and we already know Charles
has had problems you know they've talked
about the crown that Camilla may or may
not use and because the the history of
one of the Diamonds the Korean or
diamonds and what have you we know that
the royalty and many royal families
around the world were built on the backs
of slavery racism commonwealth countries
having good stolen or taken away from
them we know that unfortunately it's not
taught in school sorry
the history is racist industry without
me jumping in sorry uh great respect to
you you can't just keep talking I'm
allowed to ask questions it's an
interview right my question you're not
allowed to make statements right without
listening to what somebody says Megan
Markle made a direct charge supported by
her husband that a member of the royal
family had expressed concern about the
potential skin color of their baby which
if it was too dark would be a problem
that is racism they made a charge yes
that's called racism yeah if you think
that if a baby's too dark it's a problem
that's called racism sorry to have to
lecture you about racism I know I'm not
allowed to as a white man but actually
that is an example of racism tell us
about my history tell us about the
history of black people and what rate
and what what's that got to do with what
they said
because they didn't say it was racist
yes they did somebody else used that
word they stepped aside from using that
word I think very deliberately why did
they win in the war tell us about
unconsciously why did they tell us about
unconscious bias I'll tell you about
unconscious delusion which is they want
to know what does it mean I do the
questions you do the answering it's
called an interview show right it's
before Christmas they accepted an award
for their heroic heroic stand against
the structural racism of this royal
family based on what they told Oprah
Winfrey that was all a complete lie
there was no racism we now know they
never meant to say it was racism you're
supporting them that was never meant to
be racism queering the color of a baby
from a mixed race marriage and
expressing concern if it was going to be
too dark it's not racism Trish you take
me for a complete mug it couldn't be a
clearer example of racism why deny it
really yeah no
so so am I right in thinking that you
know better than you you I have no idea
of what racism is no I didn't say that I
didn't say that I said to you very
clearly I'm sorry that you you sorry
what do you keep doing you keep putting
words into my mouth I'm not actually
saying and the viewers aren't stupid
they can hear the conversation with them
they didn't use you want people to
believe that actually what she said
Meghan Markle to Oprah Winfrey supported
by Harry does not constitute racism
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
interview
[Music]
and it's absolutely crystal clear in
that interview what Meghan Markle was
saying supported by Harry that someone
in the royal family had expressed
concern about The Unborn baby's skin
color and when probed by Oprah if what
if the if the skin color was too dark
that would be a problem Meghan Markle
said you may well deduce that yes right
that became the biggest story of all
these Revelations is that the family is
racist yes now we're supposed to believe
that's never what they intended Harry
says that Trisha Goddard says it there's
now a kind of whole revisionist thing
going on but he's had real consequences
I didn't believe it at the time and I
had to leave my job for just believing
what was being said you then had to
leave your job because I was supporting
you because you supported my right to
free speech he didn't agree with me yeah
right um You had to go what do you feel
about this
um
it's all it's all just craziness going
around and around and he he's turned his
life and the Royal Family's life into a
soap opera it's like a really bad
distance I mean it's always been a soap
I think what's different is it's always
been speculative soap opera right you
know part of the thing of the papers he
goes on and on and on and all these
interviews and the bug I had to go
through all this the the Press are just
evil the devil he calls them all this
kind of stuff and yet the Press without
them without the Press there wouldn't be
a royal family with other press doing
predominant I mean I remember the
courage of his wedding couldn't have
been more Universal phrase beautiful he
could barely bring himself do we even
acknowledge that right this guy is so
blindly hateful of the media and British
press in particular even though he gets
exactly the same coverage in many parts
of the world but when you I mean you
haven't read the whole thing I know but
I have this is I've never read anyone
high profile talk about their family
like this
brother his sister-in-law the Queen's
dresser cops it yeah and there's a
really bad bit in here which I really
disliked which is very revealing about
his character where he trashes the
matron at Love Grove at school and he
names us Pat he calls her greasy and
ugly didn't make the boys horny right
and says that uh you know just carries
on disparaging her she had a disability
with her spine which made her she had to
walk and he used to mock her uh mock the
way she couldn't walk properly and he
boasts about this this is a guy who on
his website for Archie World their
Foundation describes as you know
standing for compassion
where's the compassion in any of this I
think well listen I'm just hearing you
picking up that story and you know I was
reporting on Harry when he was falling
in and out of nightclubs getting into
brawls with Paparazzi I mean I remember
speaking to the mother of one girl who
was dating who said he really just was
was implied he was he was rude he turned
up drunk with sick on him they didn't
want him around their goal okay and and
that was understandable this is clearly
a man who feels that he's gone through a
metamorphosis a massive reinvention and
has come out on the other side but what
was so interesting I felt about watching
the interview with Tom Bradley and I
think Bradley did a very robust very
good job with him was when he didn't
mention the Taliban had the racist
allegations as he rightly did but it was
very clear that when Harry was almost
steered off into a Zone where he wasn't
comfortable or he couldn't Channel his
his therapy speaking everything else he
looked very uncomfortable and I want to
make just one quick point on these
racism allegations I think this is very
important
when this turned into the biggest race
rail that this country has been in as
long as I can remember the biggest and
the most troubling storm for the royal
family Harren Megan came out and made it
clear in a subsequent statement that
they were not talking about the queen or
Prince Philip because of course this
Witch Hunt ensued that would have been
an ample opportunity who said and by the
way this wasn't an allegation of charge
of racism it was one of unconscious bias
I think what's happened is he realized
too late because there's a report that
he tried to get the book withdrawn that
actually this was all going too far I
think I mean the fact that he hasn't
mentioned that in here the single most
explosive Revelation isn't in the book
nor is this supposed thing with the with
the palace denying Megan help for her
Suicidal Thoughts oh yeah to make two
very very major omissions well they were
the two biggest they were the two
biggest Bombshells neither are in his
book in his life let me bring in Ben you
fantastic service to your country as a
royal marine and he was severely wounded
in the process thank you first of all
for your amazing service and it's great
to see you you know Harry you know you
fought alongside him in Afghanistan what
do you make of this
um yeah in particular the boasting about
killing 25 Taliban yeah I wasn't with
her in Afghanistan I was in a whole
different area but you were out there
you're around time um
the 25
body count thing it's just it's
obviously him in context telling the
story and he mentioned a number but I
think he could have told the story very
easily without mentioning that number I
don't think it was boasting
um about the same time if you say it and
give a number to it aren't you just
boasting I mean whichever way you're
trying to describe it he's just
literally saying what he's done which
was his job and thank God because that
was why we were able to get out of there
kind of thing because we called him and
it helped us out but I don't think
mention that number was wise would you
ever do that
no I mean the difference is if I killed
ten thousand men no one cares but if he
killed one everyone cares so it's not
wise for him to mention it it's a bit
like poking a bear as you walk past that
there's no point in
that's not under any favors um so I
don't think he's boasting it but I just
I think there's he could have easily
have said what he said without
mentioning that number and on the
specific
um racism thing was your understanding
just as a member of the public
when you watched did you watch the Oprah
interview not a lot of it you saw the
you saw the clips yeah yeah yeah was
your run was your impression that they
were saying that someone had been racist
about the skin color of their child I'll
be honest it did come across that way a
bit
um and then obviously when the media
jumps in it it I didn't think I wonder
who was racist like because it kind of
come across that way um the thing is
just in my opinion um it's almost like
you're gonna go to like a comedy show
and the Comedian says a joke that you
don't like and you're offended offended
by it
um you can say that you're offended but
the comedian doesn't have to care so you
just kind of get mad kind of thing it
seems like that's like with his family
like he's obviously not happy with
certain things and he might have said it
to them and they may not they don't have
to care they don't have to respond or
apologize because his feelings get hurt
so then he's kind of moved away supposed
to be happy in America but he's not
clearly he's not happy is it no so then
he's kind of attacking his family by
revealing everything waiting for like an
apology but you're not gonna get one I
just think everyone defending him I just
think if it was their family and someone
was going on television because they had
some kind of profile and was just doing
this endlessly trashing the family all
of them I mean it would you know you
would I think most people would cut that
personally I I still think Harry's great
I think a lot of troops do you can't
take away what he's done for this
country no no you can't
um but yes he's far out of his family
but we don't need to now see all of this
because it's so funny I just think even
though I love Harry's great guy from
what I know what I've seen I don't have
to support every move that he makes
including this one
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
books the queen actually of magazine
editing as well the queen in many
different uh spheres Tina Brown I really
wanted you on the show about this
because it's been rumbling on now for I
mean a long time what is your summary of
where we are with Harry
well the interesting part is you know
there's an expression in Psycho you know
therapy which is the extinction burst
right that when sometimes patients sort
of acted all out like throw it all out
and it just that's it it's an Extinction
burst and then they're calm so the
question is this you know is this the
Harry's Extinction burst but the problem
is with him is that he's so much in his
own bubble that he's not thinking about
or caring really about how these bullets
land I mean you know he is right now
like in his Apache helicopter like
firing these you know right but here's
the thing he regarded the Taliban as he
says very unattractively as sort of just
objects things on a chest pieces yeah
but the people he's hurting these
bullets at this time I mean these are
real people right they are his family so
how does he imagine that this Extinction
burst can now be followed with
reconciliation because it's like they've
been left like bleeding on like reeling
and you know helicopters you know would
sort of propellers go in in their face
how can they be ready for he's he's
basically said I'm going to just like
annihilate you all now I'm ready to
recognize yeah it's to me it's a very
strange well to me it's a complete joke
it's bringing Roya um I mean Roy you're
very plugged in with the Royals and the
and the Palaces what has been the
reaction of the royal family I mean just
the little bit that I know is that
they're utterly staggered by what
they've been reading and hearing uh
deeply heard and Incredibly angry and in
Prince William's case very very burying
um appears I would say all of the above
um pretty dismayed I think by the level
of detail that Harry's chosen to go into
um and I think you know one of the sort
of ongoing themes here and I've really
felt as I've read the book and he's
extraordinarily personal conversations
with members of his family emerged you
sort of wonder how he might have reacted
if the shooting on your foot and members
of his family had you know put into a
book those kind of conversations the
royal family are
pretty gross pretty angry pretty
devastated and upset
um but I think I do really think that
they will still continue to absorb all
of this and keep on and carry on
silently I don't think we're going to
get any kind of big on the record
reaction I think the hope with the royal
family is this you know when Harry's
finally done his last interview whenever
that might be
um this will
burn out and then possibly
reconciliation May begin but that's not
going to happen anytime soon I don't
think I can't imagine it happening at
all this was my family I'd never want to
see that person again let's bring in
Maureen across the pond in America I
mean there's a kind of split view really
about I think younger Americans uh
perhaps have feel a bigger Affinity with
this kind of thing they like the
outpouring of emotion all the rest of it
um but most Americans I've spoken to
over the age of about 30 share my own
revulsion about this constant constant
attack on the royal family by one of
their own
yeah you know peers it's interesting I'm
not seeing really a divide by age group
I think what we're seeing especially in
the aftermath of the Brad B interview
the 60 Minutes interview the Stray hand
interview and now he's on the cover of
people here in the states is an actual
overwhelming backlash to the sheer
number of lies he's been caught telling
you know to see him tell Tom bradby well
we never said the royal family was
racist with a stray face and blame the
British press when we have all spent the
past two years
litigating and relitigating what is
wrong in the house of of Windsor you
know and to do this to allow this light
this odious lie to stand when your
grandfather is on his deathbed when your
grandmother is in ailing Health when
you're talking about Legacy destroying
accusations how no journalist could push
back and say Harry why during any moment
during the past two years did you not
raise your hand and say you know what
media you got it wrong for someone who
loves to tell the media how much they
got it wrong this particular hypocrisy
to me is is beyond I completely agree
with you
yeah Harry has told People magazine it's
a duty a job a service to our country
I've done all I could be the best
soldier I could but truly no right or
wrong way to try and navigate these
feelings but I know from my own healing
Journey that Silence has been the least
effective remedy expressing and
detailing my experience is how I chose
to deal with it in the hopes it would
help others what's your reaction to that
justification
well I think I think he's actually in
the comments he's made I don't
personally have a huge problem with him
spelling out the numbers he's killed
everyone knows he was a a crew member of
an Apache attack helicopter whose job
was to kill the enemy I don't have an
issue with that the issue I have is with
the way he's described British army
training to teach people like him that
the Taliban and the enemy are less than
human they're just chess pieces to be
swept off the board which is dangerous
because it's wrong that's not the way
the British army is taught and it also
it shows the Army in a in a way that I
think feeds straight into jihadist
propaganda they'll use that they already
have used it to show the lack of
humanity of the British forces the way
the British forces did not treat
fighters in Afghanistan as human beings
and and it will lead I think to
radicalization and possibly to inciting
Taliban and other jihadists to carry out
attacks against British people here in
this country and elsewhere in the world
well Rob O'Neill I mean there's been a
lot of backlash to this from the British
Armed Forces certainly almost everyone
I've seen has shared the view of Colonel
Kemp that he shouldn't have gone down
this Avenue we know you as the man who
heroically shot and killed the world's
worst terrorist Osama Bin Laden and
thank you again for doing that
um we know that because you wrote about
it yourself in a book
um a great book and you talk about other
kills as well in there do you
intrinsically have any problem with what
Harry has said here
no I don't have a problem with it at all
Pierce if he goes through the proper
channels which I hope he did
um then there's not there's nothing
wrong with talking about what happened
to him war and it's just to know as far
as the history of War goes and for
future Generations as long as it's the
truth and if you're telling the truth
you don't need to remember anything else
having said uh they're like chess pieces
I think that's giving them a compliment
because it's not that complex the man's
flying on Apache helicopter a kill
helicopter and he's giving him a little
bit of credit I mean it's not like
islamists are going to like us any less
or want to kill us more because of
something Prince Harry said and it's you
know the connies are saying it the
connies of Benji hotties and criminals
traffickers and drug pushers since since
the Russians invaded so it's not like
they're great people either
um yeah I mean he said what he said and
I think he was he was nice about it it
was up to me and they were actually
terrorists I wish he would have killed
more I mean somebody said that there's a
big difference between a British soldier
or someone like you for example killing
a hundred Taliban and a member of the
royal family killing one that the
amplification of the fact he's a member
of the royal family doing this does put
a bigger security risk Target against
the royal family against him and his
family now in California and potentially
against British troops
because of who he is well like I was
saying I mean there's there's been a
Target on them forever and there will be
and you know it's not like if he if he'd
said nothing they could put their heads
in the sand and pretend they're not
targets they are targets I hope their
security is uh you know on point I hope
you know hope they're fine but the
realization there are people that are
going to hate him and me and you just
the same you know as always and you know
they're going to prop this up they're
putting Afghanistan back on the map and
Hillman province which is dangerous on
the map but you know he said what he
said and I'm glad he said it and and um
you know we can learn from what people
did there if you had had a spa have you
got any brothers I I don't know the
answer to that question
yeah I've got an older brother and as
far as getting beat up again
if your older brother had knocked you
into a dog bowl and broken your necklace
would you have ever put that into the
public domain or would you have felt
that that would be probably the most
shameful admission you could ever make
well being a younger brother like I said
I always I tell my brother he was the
reason I joined the Navy just so I come
back and kick his butt um and you know
it all depends on the size of the
contract if I need to rub some dirt on
my brother to get some cash who knows
what do you make it Rob of this I mean
you're one of the most famous guys in
America what do you make of this uh
Harry and Megan ongoing saga do you care
well you know I am married and Jessica
loves it so I hear about I had to tell
her the other day look Jessica as much
as I love to talk to you about this I'm
out of talking points I don't care
enough to do it I mean I I you know I
have never met uh either one of them and
I wish them the best uh it is
entertaining once in a while but I can't
get into it that much when there's uh
other things in life that are more
important to me do you ever think that
maybe if if King George III had not been
so useless we could have still had a
royal family in America possibly even
King peers by now
you know yeah King Pierce I tell you
what if we want to make uh campaign
posters for 2024 put me on there with
you buddy
I think I could have done a good job on
the throne of America uh Robin Hill uh
great to talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys where do you think you're going
look we're cool with John we swear uh
we've got a strict admission policy in
here and you're not getting in with
those trainers on
[Music]
foreign
ergy nasal spray dust of the vista baby
safe to use for all noses
[Music]
I'm joined by the black lives matter
activist Iman Ayden and the author and
friend of Prince Harry and former rugby
International James Haskell welcome to
both of you so to be sitting very
patiently there listening to be tear
into your mate am I wrong I've never
seen you in full flow actually it's
quite terrifying I was wondering what's
going to happen if you got a bit shouty
and I was trying to think can I am I
articulate enough I'm intelligent enough
to take Piers Morgan on well I have seen
you in full fly in a Rugby field and you
have another way of dealing with that's
what I feel like so I think on this
banners I'll keep you just thought
violence could be the answer
and look I think it's interesting
because obviously you're very invested
in the in the story I think there's a
lot of people well I'll tell you before
you you Oliver I just want to say the
reason I'm so personally invested I
think people know why is because I
queried a lot of these things at the
time and I for example when the when the
Oprah exchange with Meghan Markle about
racism was playing we'll play it now so
you can remind yourselves and I'll tell
you what then happened let's watch this
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like to hold it hold up there's
several there's several conversations
there's a conversation with you with
Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
I think that would be very damaging to
them okay compartmentalize they were
concerned that if you were to
Brown
that that would be a problem are you
saying that
I wasn't able to follow up with why but
that if that's the Assumption you're
making I think that feels like a pretty
safe one
here's the thing James I the morning
after that aired on Good Morning Britain
I came out fighting and I said I just
don't believe that I don't believe a
senior member of the royal family would
have expressed concern that if the
baby's skin color was too dark that
would be a problem and I wanted to see
the evidence I also said that when she
talked about having suicidal thoughts
and then situated with the palace spoke
to officials and they said she couldn't
get help for it I said I just can't
believe that conversation has happened I
want to see the evidence for two years
no evidence emerged it's not in his book
either of those things they don't appear
in the book of his life and now he just
casually says well we never meant it to
be racism that was the evil British
press now look I get why he hates the
Press I get it he thinks the Press
killed his mother I think a drunk driver
killed his mother and I think that she
was obsessively followed by the
paparazzi and too much so and I've
always said that but ultimately the
inquest determined it was a drunk driver
it was a predominant cause of her death
but he hates the pressure Because he
believes that the press conspired to
kill his mother so I get why he feels
the way he does but that doesn't give
him license to Brand his family a bunch
of races allow two years of this kind of
onslaught headline so damaging to the
Royals reputation and you know like you
do a podcast with Mike Tindall you know
you know you know how they all feel
about this and then to just to casually
say we didn't mean that
yeah look I think when I put it like
that does part of you think even though
you're a mate no look I think I'm always
very objective about everything you know
just as a people with my own expect my
friend to be objective about me you know
I don't get things right all the time I
I saw the documentary and and I've read
only a little bit of the book because
only got it the other day I'm a slow
reader as you imagine being a rugby
player and and you know one of the
things I've I've felt as zless is their
celebrity right it's incomparable to
someone like Carrie I understand how the
media uh on always hold accountable they
can take things and put their
interpretation on it yeah part of the
stuff that he talked about in his book
because of the manuscript's stolen right
and a lot of this Sensational stuff
because it was so uh out there was taken
out of context yeah but hang on I've
read it all yes I literally spent six
hours on Tuesday reading the whole thing
the point about the Taliban Revolution
for example was twofold one the British
army guy they just don't put a number on
it in public they might to each other no
I agree with that they don't do it in
public you know that you've spoken for
enough of them secondly dehumanizing the
enemy to a bunch of chess pieces that
again is not something they do in public
they might in the bar yeah but they know
that there is a certain code that comes
with being a British Army uh
either officer or one of the one of the
troops and you don't you don't cross
that line I mean I think I think look
you're looking at kind of it with the
intense intention with the particular
details when I'm talking more as an
overarching view of saying when someone
is in his position more often not the
belief from being part of the royal
family was never complained never
explain never comment about anything
right firstly we've got to break this
this idea that they're not just a normal
family because they absolutely are
dysfunctional normal family that
everybody has well they're not a normal
family well but no because they live in
palaces they do but and the British
taxpayer pays for you they don't pay for
you and me no but when they scrape that
away because they are simply still
humans I know people think I know lots
of them
I agree they're human beings yes so if
you if you take that to a point and in
his position you very rarely get to tell
your story without people a journalist
interviewing you so you and I are on TV
today right you think this could be
edited up and bits of it could be could
be altered or if you were right do a
written interview your interpretation is
written out it's not what actually says
so I feel that he has written this book
as a way of going look in regardless of
what happened this is what I feel and
I'm not saying whether it's true or not
I've got no comment I don't really care
to be honest with you but I'm saying
he's put this out there to go this is my
version I finally got an opportunity to
speak now whether he should have spoken
what he said was right or wrong that's
another story I just feel that people in
that position don't often get to tell
the story and I think he's done it in a
way that most of his peers and most of
his family have never had the
opportunity to do and that's I think for
me that's important because it cannot be
misinterpreted or or shouldn't be
misinter let me tell you what would
happen if they all did what he's done
the monarchy would die I agree and the
mistake would go agreed they would
become a real-life soap opera right it
would be utterly catastrophic for the
reputation of the royal family in the
monarchy of all they did was thrown mud
at each other in public and the monarchy
would die but one of the last surviving
monarchies is it is but I think
interestingly in his particular
situation with what happened to his
mother for example right and again you
know in your own words you said you know
what she hounded to the nth degree yes
yeah and and do you see what happens
with the royal family for example that
the Zeitgeist of how popularity goes one
minute one of them is the best things in
its life spread the next is because
that's why but that's why they have to
play the long game I mean the queen
mother was a great example she never
gave an interview in order the daughter
of the queen she was absolutely of the
Mantra never complained never explained
because she just thought over time it
all balances out you get the great stuff
we've had the Jubilee but I think in the
modern and you get the negative stuff I
think just in but in the modern world
right when they were when they were sort
of when she was reigning and when the
queen mother was alive you didn't have
social media you didn't have instant
comments you didn't have 24-hour news
that that is a new feature and the
problem is I don't think it matters well
I think it does because because the way
it spreads and the nature of things like
trolling you cannot get the truth out
there so for example I follow you on
Twitter you know I'm a big fan of what
you what you you do it in lots of Parts
but you're very defensive of yourself so
when someone questions you of course you
will come out and tell the truth if I'm
a journalist I'm not a member no but but
he is also a human that I think
he's put up with a lot of rubbish so
just as you would defend yourself I
would defend myself the difference is
what he does now actually has some
weight because when for example if you
wrote an article about me in the paper
and it was wrong and I got an apology
it's page 37. if I did a video on social
media after that you you made a me head
uh front page article maybe 20 people
see it yeah he has now put a like a
flagpole or a mark in the ground to say
this is my true this is my story now you
can debate it to the nth degree whether
that's factually correct but I think
that's just important for him
Prince Harry says he's a feminist uh so
in his own words here's how he talks
about women from his mother-in-law to be
disabled matron at his school
you wrote I even wanted Camila to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
how is she dangerous because of the need
for her to rehabilitate her image that
made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press I want to sort of just briefly
talk about your stepmother and press
because you you were pretty consistently
scathing and suggest that you are
scathing
well scaling towards well as in you say
that your interests were sacrificed on
her PR altered I think of the book is
very clear what happened there's no part
of any of the things that I've said are
scathing towards any member of my family
especially not my stepmother unlike the
other matrons Pat wasn't hot Pat was
called that was small walking was hard
stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh who the
hell is this editor
loathsome toad I gathered
everyone who knew her was in full
agreement that she was an infected
posture on the ass of humanity plus
excuse for a journalist
now that it happens to be a good friend
of mine uh and yeah not a nice way to
speak about a woman right especially
someone who gets so uptight when people
use that kind of language about his wife
well joining me now is journalist and
friend of Camilla page another Wyatt the
son's Royal photographer friend of
everybody Arthur Edwards and the
journalist and historian Dr Tessa Dunlop
oh let me start with you because you've
covered the Royals for longer than I've
been alive sorry not quite it's sort of
John that one only 40 years
um you know them you've known them all
very very well what what do you make of
this this book and the interviews around
it well I've you know I'm pretty
disgusted the way they said about
Camilla because uh she is just the
nicest person and you know when she
married the prince
he risked everything for that there was
a lot of hostility towards him over that
but you know what she just got her head
down and worked and worked and worked I
remember those early jobs with her she
was so nervous but she kept trying try
and try and then in the end people got
to love her because they found what a
really nice person she is
and Harry just trashing her like that I
was so I really wanted this smacking one
you know I thought it was an awful thing
to do is she's been nothing but nice to
him I remember once when he you know I
think it was 2000 2017 and he made some
stupid mistakes a statement about he
didn't want to remember the real family
anymore
and I remember talking to her about the
next day she said you know he's such a
lovely boy all she said was how nice he
was you know speaking listen I've known
Camila alongside she comes from the next
door Village to me I've known her a long
time in her family they're incredibly
nice people very down to earth very
normal I had lunch with a um this now
Infamous lunch with Jeremy Clarkson was
out before Christmas uh she was utterly
delightful to everyone and I don't think
she deserves this would be called a
dangerous villain by by Prince Harry as
we head towards a coronation where her
and Charles are gonna you know be
crowned our king and queen of this
country I just felt was so damaging and
unnecessary defend it I just would like
as it's all about truth and accuracy I'm
not sure he called her a dangerous
villain a villain and dangerous no he
explained that she was the villain of
the peace because she was The Other
Woman slightly taken out of context in
fact that line it just just but he knows
what he's right he knows when he writes
those things that'll be the headline
you're credited him with High um
intelligence and I think Harry used to
do things I don't think he's stupid
actually I don't think anyone would
accuse me I think he has high EQ these
are high ego and we're seeing the full
blast of it right now what about the way
he generally talks about women just can
we just pick up on the Camilla thing
what you two have both said that she's
Charming that you know she's the woman
next door literally for you the village
next door that she does have this very
natural way she's comfortable in her
skin she fits in she gets on with it she
loves the Gin she loves the [ __ ] we all
love Camilla do you know when that
replaces your dead mother and when you
feel like an outsider
because on bridge there yeah but sure
there's a feeling hang on but hang on
his mother died in 1997. well now 2022.
he's nearly 40 years old all right
they're just there comes a title it's
2023. there comes a time when you just
have to not move on and forget your
mother but actually accept your father's
very happy with a woman be married to
the 17 years why would you try and ruin
her reputation in the run-up to the
coronation I think there's probably
aspects of jail
where she has managed to rehabilitate
her her image and interestingly she's
Latin Britain she hasn't successfully
done that in other Realms or indeed
within the Commonwealth where things are
on much it hasn't been given a chance
yes it is therefore his point stands
really that this I don't it is about her
ability to work alongside the Press of
which both of you two are significant
players sure so that point stands now
it's after his relationship with his
stepmother only they know the real truth
don't they and we're only hearing well
we're never gonna we're never going to
hear Camilla's side Camilla has other
things no no Camila will know that she
will never respond to any of this that's
why I feel sorry for all the rules
because they're trapped now with this
hand grenade going the thing is that
Camilla had to endure
such vicious attacks from the press and
a level of violence from the public that
Megan
um
it was never even close I remember when
Camilla had bread rolls
well she says it's not true maybe it
wasn't but there was she really was at
one point the most hated woman in
Britain and the stuff about this poor
matron Pat Jones she has a name Pat
Jones she was the matron at Love Grove
School he calls her greasy he calls her
ugly none of the boys got horny when
they saw her she had a spinal deficiency
which he mocked and did it in person he
mopped the way exactly defend any of
that why does he have to talk about
todgers
take down his matron I want to make two
points one to answer your specific
question on the matron that is
Preparatory School mentality oh really
yeah I mean I think they should be
confined to the dust why would you put
it in a book guess what it is why when
you're supposed to be a great feminist
why would you why would you annihilate
innocent woman we don't even know if
she's alive or not but with her family
and brothers but this was probably
something she talked about I I was a
matrix says just hang on it was written
now actually it was quite poetic that
people it wasn't perfect
wait let me finish my peace
it ends up the payoff is actually the
great joy for this boy who's just lost
his mother is to make all the kids laugh
and then and I'm going what would we do
for him
wait let me read the line I loved
cracking my mates up but nothing quite
did it for me like making the otherwise
miserable Pat Buster gun right how does
that feel she laughs
she wouldn't be laughing at a
description of herself in the fastest
selling book of the history of being
greasy ugly
I thought it was totally I'm sorry I
think it's totally it is a servant she
had to laugh she had no choice jumping
is the Rose between two Thorns the film
Between Two Roses I think well I I look
going back to Harry I mean so he was
saying about Camilla using the media no
one used it more than Harry right I mean
we we went everywhere in the world with
him and he was fantastic and I remember
at the end of the day we'd all go to the
pub and we'd have a drink with him and
and he would get it all off his chest
but you know he used to say to us I do
my best to give you great pictures every
day I want to get in the paper you know
get it in the paper get these promote
these causes
that I'm picturing a patron of he was
brilliant so you know having to go about
Camilla doing exactly the same thing
it's just the brass I I don't know I'm
sorry I just read that book I put it
down this guy is just a spoiled entitled
victimhood Laden
so he is also
um I think he's deeply unhappy because a
happy he's so unhappy does not write
that kind of book he knows it's going to
hurt and a self-proclaimed protective
women's reputations and someone who
objected to anyone who suggested that
Megan Google the royal family or somehow
scheme to marry into it says um that
Camilla scheme to marry Charles and
become Queen consulate but I think we're
all losing sight of the bigger picture I
hear peace in tone on your love
understandable love for the monarchy
here we have Andrew Edwards MBE
physicists Arthur Edwards
writes favorably about the roles in The
Spectator regularly you're passionate
Royal it's more so than me I'm also a
royalist by the way but if we want this
institution to survive it's no good
getting in behind our bunker and going
go away everyone else
what we're saying all right imagine for
a moment imagine now that William does
his version it's not going to exactly
Kate does hers
uh Camilla does says the royal family
would collapse there would be no royal
family there'd be no monarchy they would
be sent off to some part of Europe and
that'd be the last we'd ever see them
like every other monarchy virtually in
Europe right so we have one of the last
great monarchies and that's why I care I
care when this little Renegade duo in
California I'm making hundreds of
millions of dollars spray gunning this
family and the institution whilst
trading off the Royal titles they've
been given I think is totally disgusting
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]